it takes a lot for a kid to steal the
spotlight from Deadpool but Julianne
Denison has a superhuman amount of
charisma a native of New Zealand the
young actor plays Russell the mysterious
mutant at the center of Deadpool - it's
a huge role for Denison a
self-proclaimed Marvel movie fan but
it's far from his first he's been and
critically acclaimed indie flix hugely
popular viral videos and one of the most
legitimately entertaining body spray
commercials ever made here's why the kid
from Deadpool - looks so familiar
shopping Denison was just a shy student
from the suburbs of New Zealand - when
the filmmakers for the coming-of-age
film shopping came to his school looking
for a young actor to star in the film
Denison's mom told stuff that the
filmmakers narrowed down the search to
Denison or his twin brother Christian
the film premiered at the Sundance Film
Festival in 2013 and instantly turned
Denison into a local celebrity he won
Best Supporting Actor at the New Zealand
Film Awards and credits the experience
with him wanting to become an actor
blazed Denison's debut in shopping
didn't just impress the critics it also
brought him one incredibly important fan
Taika Waititi the oscar-nominated
director of the 2004 short film two cars
one night who would eventually go on to
helm thor ragnarok ytt thought Denison
would be perfect for his next project an
extended public service announcement
about the dangers of driving under the
influence of marijuana the two-minute
video for the New Zealand Transport
Agency features three kids who imitate
the antics of they're stoned fathers
behind the wheel of a car Denison is
hilarious throughout much of the clip
but he also shows a hint of depth in the
final moments the commercial became a
viral sensation and generated headlines
around the world I love this music
full music it also created a bond
between y TT and Dennison that would
yield another successful collaboration
down the road Paper Planes Denison's
next appearance on the big screen came
courtesy of a supporting role in the
family drama Paper Planes and uplifting
tale about a boy in Australia who dreams
of competing in the world paper plane
championships in Japan Dennison plays
Kevin a school bully who eventually
becomes the best friend of the main
character acclaimed Australian director
Robert Connolly co-wrote and directed
the film with an impressive cast that
includes Sam Worthington while the movie
performed well at the Australian
box-office it was far less successful in
the rest of the world still critics
couldn't help but notice Denison even in
a smaller role the New Zealand Herald
said he turned in a scene-stealing
performance as the reformed bully Kevin
hunts for the wilderkin if you recognize
Denison from anything prior to Deadpool
- its most likely hunt for the wilter
people the heartwarming comedy that
served as his official breakthrough
writer and director Taika Waititi didn't
even make the young actor audition for
the role of Riki Baker a juvenile
delinquent taken to live on a remote
farm with a loving foster mother and her
cranky husband Hector you can read what
should do those people like race by like
leaves or something but after a sudden
tragedy leads Ricci to ineptly attempt
to fake his own death he and Hector go
on the run into the New Zealand bush and
become the targets of a comical manhunt
Denison took a month away from school to
work on the movie but it was definitely
worth it
hunt for the wildered at the Sundance
Film Festival and became the top
grossing New Zealand film of all time
it also directly paved the way for
denizens part in Deadpool - Ryan
Reynolds told the New Zealand Herald the
casting was partly a result of his
friendship with white titi who
co-starred with Reynolds in 2011's Green
Lantern you got sprung after hunt for
the wildered Dennis and one of the most
recognizable people in New Zealand he
put a star power to use in a completely
unexpected
in 2016 he teamed up with Air New
Zealand for a clip to celebrate the
start of spring and random acts of
kindness day he and a sort of Kiwi
version of pay it forward Dennison
travelled around the country to surprise
unsuspecting people with thoughtful
gestures like Santa Claus but in spring
in the clip Dennis and pays for people's
meals at a restaurant takes flowers and
chocolates to patients in a hospital and
gives out free ice cream
so another awesome idea of ours to put a
spring back into someone step
what's the frog bangers barley he ends
the video by calling on New Zealanders
to surprise others with kindness and
we'd be shocked if he didn't inspire at
least a few to do just that Kronus
Thessia about four months after hunt for
the wilted people hit theatres in New
Zealand Denison returned to the big
screen for a small role in a very
different type of movie he played Benny
in the indie time travel romance
Kronus theisha the film was made in
Wellington New Zealand with next to no
budget and a pair bones crew Pro
Nastasia premiered at the New Zealand
International Film Festival in 2016 but
it largely flew under the radar in
America summer wonderland in late 2016
Denison showed up in another video for
Air New Zealand and this time he had a
noteworthy pal in summer wonderland
Denison shows up in a recording studio
where Irish popstar Ronan Keating is
recording a take on the holiday classic
winter wonderland
but Keating doesn't make it past the
second line before Denison interrupts
the Roman to the Roman slow down here
Keating eventually walks out but the
pair soon work out a new version of the
song that's more appropriate for the
climate Keating said in a press release
that he signed on for the project
because he's a big fan of New Zealand
but he also loved collaborating with
Denison
he said working with Julian was a breeze
he's an absolute legend incredibly
professional and to top it off he
definitely can sing
riki links Australia if you want a video
to go viral it's become increasingly
clear that denizen should be involved
the people at links body spray must have
known this and in early 2018 they teamed
with him for an extended commercial for
their Australia fragrance in the
commercial Dennison plays Humphrey a kid
who doesn't have the best luck with the
ladies while his older brother Darius is
good at everything
he's just so chilling Copeland it is a
talk to goose strange behavior for Kiwi
you know Darius eventually reveals his
secret is links Australia the ad ran on
TV and before movies and theaters in
Australia but it reached audiences
around the world when they hit the
Internet less than three months after it
was released the ad had millions of
views on YouTube thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]